- When the book was released,
a lot of people kind of made
it about a coming out party,
story for you,
but that wasn't really
why you made the book.
Right?
- I am very naive in how I
tell my story in the sense that
putting this book together
for four and a half years.
To me, I thought the
most interesting story
about my journey is being a young man of
color in Hollywood and
navigating what that's like.
And then finally getting
the chance to work
in the industry I love.
Going to work for the
first black president of
The United States.
What's that like.
- And like also just coming
from entertainment industry
and making that move and then
still being a part of it,
that's interesting.
- So I am just so excited to
share that full breath of my
experiences and story with people
and it's been really fun
to write and get the
whole thing out there.
- I love that. I think four
years, that's so much time.
So it's like your baby,
but I love that you showed
every different kind of
part of your life.
I think that's really
cool and it lets people in
and also inspires people
that you can dream big
and you can make it happen. I love that.
- Thank you.
My two goals When I was
putting the book together,
I said I want to write a book
for the 25 year-old version of me.
The kid who's like trying to figure out
how to make things work.
And there's no guidebook for that.
And I also want to write it
for the person who's out there
who has multiple passions, right?
Who doesn't view the world as binary or
doesn't view things as mutually exclusive
and says, I like this and that
and maybe I'm going to take a chance.
Maybe I'm going to do that
crazy thing that everybody said
you shouldn't do because it's crazy.
Especially
- You only live once, why not?
- You only live once,
especially through the pandemic.
So many people realized,
wait, I don't like what I'm doing now or
I want to add that other thing.
So this story is also for them
and sharing my experiences
with all of that stuff.
- And that's so true,
Everybody did like you kind of,
I literally just was texting
last night with with a friend,
I was like,
I literally have regular
talks with my therapist.
I'm just like wait, I'm
doing what I love, Right?
And I am doing what I love,
but you have that conversation like
if I had a year to live,
what would I be doing?
Like, you know, I always have
this conversation and it is
I think that COVID did
that to a lot of us.
It made us really like
question the time we spend with
each other and like what,
are really doing we love?
which I do love what I'm doing.
- Same, I feel so lucky
- Yeah, I know I'm super glad